kann aber dort nicht besucht werden
sondern beendet den dienst im bereich
des bahnhofsplatzes und kann erst dort
in empfang genommen werden
meine damen und herren in wenigen
minuten beginnt der festakt mit dem
ankündigung signal gespielt von einem
trompeter der gardemusik danach mit ihr
der kommandant der ausgerückten truppe
oberst stefan kirchebner dem herrn
bundespräsidenten nach der bundeshymne
und dem abschreiten der front erfolgt
die flaggenparade
mein kommando sprechen als das ganze
[Musik]
das ganze hab oft ihre information
schult ihre information pressemeldungen
herrn bundespräsidenten das ganze
rechtsschutz
herr bundespräsident das kirchheimer
meldet eine information der garde und
1048 soldatinnen und soldaten zur
feierlichen angelobung
[Musik]
das ganze hab oft ihre information
schreibt ihre information risk großen
flagge börde das ganze rechtsschutz
[Musik]
als ganze ihre information schult ihre
information bei dass ganze parade meine
damen und herren es erfolgt nun die
begrüßung durch den militärkommandanten
von wien herrn bringt ihr magister kurt
wagner im anschluss hören sie die
ansprache des bürgermeisters und
landeshauptmannes von wien herrn dr
michael ludwig danach spielt die
gardemusik den marsch wien bleibt wien
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren der
nationalfeiertag ist seit vielen jahren
sehr eng mit dem österreichischen
bundesheer verbunden als
militärkommandant von wien darf ich sie
zur diesjährigen informations und
leistungsschau des bundesheeres um zur
angelobung herzlich willkommen heißen
im rahmen unserer veranstaltung die
heuer bereits zum 24
mal durchgeführt wird dürfen ihnen das
vielfältige aufgabenspektrum des
bundesheeres darstellen
wir weisen aber auch darauf hin dass das
bundesheer bereits jetzt nur mehr sehr
eingeschränkt in der lage ist seine
aufgaben zu erfüllen
nur wenn das österreich geschäft das er
auch die notwendigen finanziellen mittel
erhält kann der schutz der
österreicherinnen und österreicher
sichergestellt werden
ich danke ihnen allen dass sie so
zahlreich bei diesem festakt der
angelobung dabei sind vor uns sind mehr
als 1000 rekruten unsere gruppen
angetreten
sie kommen aus ganz österreich und
werden heute angelobt sie vereint die
bereitschaft sich mit allen ihren
kräften für die republik österreich und
die bevölkerung einzusetzen
dazu werden sie verschiedenste
tätigkeiten im bundesheer übernehmen zum
beispiel im rahmen der karte bei den
pionieren bei der luftunterstützung oder
in einer verwendung als funktion soldat
sie tragen damit gemeinsam mit
berufssoldaten und milizsoldaten zur
verfassungsmässigen aufgabenerfüllung
der österreichischen bundesheeres bei
und sie stehen daher zu recht heute im
mittelpunkt dieser feier
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
begrüßen sie mit mir unsere rekrutinnen
und rekruten die heute angelobt werden
eine besondere auszeichnung für diese
angelobung stellt die anwesenheit der
höchsten vertreter der republik
österreich da ein respektvoller groß
geht um herrn bundespräsidenten und
gleichzeitig ober grieshaber des
österreichischen bundesheeres doktor
alexander van der bellen
[Applaus]
es freut mich die bundeskanzlerin mit
österreich dr in brigitte bierlein in
unserer mitte begrüßen zu dürfen
[Applaus]
es ist eine besondere ehre präsidentin
des nationalrates und des bundesrates
unter uns zu begrüßen
mit ihnen darf ich auch alle
abgeordneten so der gesetzgebenden
körperschaften begriffen herzlich
willkommen präsident des bundesrates
kader und zweite präsidentin des
nationalrates doris bures
[Applaus]
ich darf alle mitglieder der
bundesregierung begrüßen und respektvoll
der bundesminister für
landesverteidigung magister thomas
stallinger in unserer mitte willkommen
heißen
einen herzlichen willkommensgruß und
bildlich dem landeshauptmann und
bürgermeister von wien boxer michael
ludwig und mit ihm allen vertretern der
politik und der verwaltung der stadt
training ein herzliches grüß gott
wünsche ich stellvertretend für alle
vertreter der religionen und
glaubensgemeinschaften dem
militärbischof für österreich dr werner
freistetter ich freue mich
stellvertretung für alle angehörigen des
bundesministeriums für
landesverteidigung und des
österreichischen bundesheeres den chef
des generalstabes des österreichischen
bundesheeres general magister robert
preacher respektvoll begrüßen zu dürfen
[Applaus]
pauschal lasse ich die vorsitzenden der
parlamentarischen bundesheerkommission
alle weiteren spitzen des öffentlichen
lebens der justiz der exekutive der
wirtschaft und der medien sowie ganz
besonders herzlich die angehörigen und
freunde unsere anzüge lobenden
willkommen
ich danke ihnen allen für kommen
[Applaus]
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren ich
wünsche unseren jüngsten soldatinnen und
soldaten eine fordernde und
erlebnisreiche zeit beim bundesheer und
allen besucherinnen und besuchern
unserer informations und leistungsschau
etwas interessantes zu sehen
vielen dank sehr geehrter herr
bundespräsident frau bundeskanzlerin
herr vizekanzler hochgeschätzte
mitglieder der bundesregierung wird der
mitglieder des national und bundesrates
der landtage hochgeschätzte vertreter
der religionsgemeinschaften lieber
rekrutinnen und rekruten als
bürgermeister und landeshauptmann von
wien möchte ich sie alle ganz herzlich
hier im herzen der bundeshauptstadt
begrüßen
es ist ein platz der mit den schülern
aber auch schmerzhaften zeiten unseres
landes ganz eng verbunden war und ist
hier hat im märz 1938 das
menschenverachtende regime der nazis die
macht über unser land übernommen
den zweiten weltkrieg ausgelöst
das menschheitsverbrechen der shoah
viele politisch andersdenkende
vertrieben verfolgt ermordet
von daher begehen wir hier auf diesem
platz jedes jahr am 8
zum gedenken an das ende dieses
furchtbaren regimes und des zweiten
weltkrieges ein fest der freude und es
war in der tat nach ende des zweiten
weltkrieges eine zeit über die sich die
bevölkerung gefreut hat und sie hat sich
gesehnt nach frieden nach freiheit nach
unabhängigkeit und das war der grund
dass am 26
oktober 1955 der wiener nationalrat
beschlossen hat der österreichische
nationalrat im wiener parlament dass es
eine immerwährende neutralität für unser
land geben soll
mit dem
bild dass wir eine zone des friedens
sind das ist auch gelungen
wir präsentieren uns als ein land der
unabhängigkeit wir sind stolz eine
nation zu sein
wir wirken mit bei internationalen
friedenssichernden maßnahmen und hier
ist das österreichische bundesheer ein
wichtiges instrument das zeit wir
verteidigen unsere neutralität unsere
demokratie unser land und wir beteiligen
uns auch an internationalen
friedensmissionen weil wir wissen
frieden in der welt bedeutet auch
frieden in unserem land und wir leben in
anderen zeiten aus nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg vor 30 jahren ist der eiserne
vorhang gefallen
eine brutale grenze die nicht nur zwei
systeme getrennt hat sondern unseren
wunderbaren kontinent in dieser
damaligen situation war österreich war
wien in einer randlage nach dem fall des
eisernen vorhanges waren wir im zentrum
europas in einem gemeinsamen europa und
war ziemlich genau vor einem
vierteljahrhundert sind wir der
europäischen union beigetreten und zu
recht hat die europäische union den
friedensnobelpreis bekommen dafür dass
wir an unseren kontinent in frieden
leben können
das österreichische bundesheer leistet
hier einen wesentlichen und wichtigen
beitrag
die vereinten nationen haben ihren sitz
in wien gefunden dank auch der
bestrebungen des legendären
sozialdemokratischen bundeskanzler bruno
kreisky und das österreichische
bundesheer beteiligt sich an missionen
der vereinten nationen zur
friedenssicherung aber das
österreichische bundesheer setzt sich
auch ein in unserem land wenn es
katastrophen gibt wenn es
umwelteinflüsse gibt die die bevölkerung
bedrohen und das österreichische
bundesheer berufssoldaten präsenzdienst
sind dabei
wenn es darum geht die bevölkerung zu
bewahren bzw auswirkungen von
naturkatastrophen zu vermindern und von
daher ist es heute eine gute gelegenheit
auch danke zu sagen danke zu sagen der
im österreichischen bundesheer das in
allen bundesländern so viel geleistet
wird ein bindeglied ist in unserer
nation auch zwischen den bundesländern
aber die politik hat auch die
verantwortung die entsprechenden
ressourcen zur verfügung zu stellen dass
das österreichische bundesheer diese
wichtigen aufgaben auch erfüllen kann
und wir sollten gemeinsam über die
parteigrenzen hinweg darauf achten dass
jene soldatinnen und soldaten die den
dienst für unser land leisten auch die
entsprechenden ressourcen haben die
entsprechenden rahmenbedingungen ihren
dienst zu leisten
lieber rekrutinnen und rekruten
ich kann eure situation gut
nachempfinden vor ziemlich genau vier
jahrzehnten bin ich selbst angelobt
worden
und ich kann mich noch gut erinnern dass
mich dieser moment sehr bewegt hat aber
ich möchte nicht verhehlen
vielleicht geht's ihnen kann sagen dass
man ist schon lang standen es ist schon
ziemlich heiß das drucken die schuhe
es gibt viele reden und eigentlich
stellt man den feiertag lieber mit der
familie mit der freundin verbringen
aber das wird diese zeremonie heute hier
im zentrum unserer stadt der
bundeshauptstadt wien gemeinsam erleben
dürfen hat von den sinn ihnen danke zu
sagen danke zu sagen dass er sich in den
dienst des österreichischen bundesheeres
stehen wir sind stolz auf sie
wir die politischen repräsentanten
unseres landes ihre familienangehörigen
ihre freundinnen und freunde die
gekommen sind sich ebenfalls ganz
herzlich willkommen heißen möchte und
wir möchten ihnen danke sagen und ich
wünsche ihnen für die kommenden monate
alles gute und dass sie so wie ich viele
interessante stunden beim
österreichischen bundesheer erleben
werden manchen drückenden dienst aber
auch viel freundschaft viel
kameradschaft und das gefühl
sich für unser gemeinsames land
einzusetzen in diesem sinne
es lebe das österreichische bundesheer
es lebe unser heimatland die republik
österreich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es erfolgt nun die ansprache des
bundesministers für landesverteidigung
magister thomas starlinger danach
spricht bundeskanzlerin dr brigitte
bierlein im anschluss hören sie den
marsch o du mein österreich
hoch geschätzter herr bundespräsident
sehr geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin
er hat der mitglieder der
bundesregierung des bundes und des
nationalrates
sehr geehrter generalstabschef liebe
herr bürgermeister vielen dank fürs
wetter heute soldatinnen und soldaten
sehr geehrte damen und herren aber vor
allem gilt mein gruß den anzug bei den
soldatinnen und soldaten
der nationalfeiertag hat für die
republik österreich und seine
bevölkerung eine ganz besondere
bedeutung
am 26 oktober 1955 wurde im nationalrat
die immer währen der neutralität als
teil der verfassung beschlossen
österreich hat er nach einer
zehnjährigen besatzungs dauer endlich
seine staatliche souveränität wieder
erlangt die neutralität ist seit damals
ein zentrales element der
österreichischen außenpolitik geworden
das bedeutet aber nicht sich einfach
passiv zu verhalten in der hoffnung es
werde schon nichts passieren das
bundesheer wird dir in zweierlei
hinsicht einerseits durch den schutz der
bevölkerung und der kritischen
infrastruktur im inland und durch die
teilnahme an internationalen einsätzen
im ausland
das geht jedoch nur mit einem starken
und einsatzbereiten bundesheer mit dem
im september erschienenen bericht unser
heer 20.30 haben wir dargelegt welche
bedrohungen gegen österreich gibt und
wie das bundesheer die österreichische
bevölkerung schützen kann
aber was sind denn nur solche
bedrohungen
denken sie an einen selber handlich der
zum blackout führt sowie die strom- und
wasserversorgung lahm legen kann und
damit für großes chaos in der
bevölkerung sorgt denken sie an eine
militärisch organisierten terror angriff
bei dem die terroristen
über panzerfäuste schwere waffen und
nachtsichtgeräte verfügen und deren
angriffe zahlreiche tote und
schwerstverletzte bieten
denken sie an mögliche anschläge auf die
kritische infrastruktur wie kraftwerke
straßen oder die eisenbahn mit schweren
schäden für die österreichische
volkswirtschaft
denken sie an den klimawandel
der für noch mehr ressourcen knappheit
den krisenländern sorgt und viele
menschen nach europa aufbrechen lässt
oder denken sie an angriffe mit drohnen
und großveranstaltungen wie diese kann
damit ein abruptes ende gesetzt und eine
massenpanik ausgelöst werden
was ist aber nun die rolle des
bundesheeres im rahmen eines gesamtstaat
in einer gesamtstaatlichen reaktion auf
diese bedrohungen cyber experten des
heeres müssen angriffe auf unsere
netzwerke abwehren und darauf reagieren
können
soldaten müssen kraftwerke straßen und
die heißen dann schützen und in enger
zusammenarbeit mit der polizei
die öffentliche sicherheit waren können
hubschrauber und gepanzerte fahrzeuge
müssen gruppen schnell und sicher
dorthin verbringen können wo sie
benötigt werden
unsere militärische fliegerabwehr muss
drohnen bekämpfen können und zu luft
bauen unsere staatsgrenzen in der luft
müssen überwacht und geschützt werden
können
in unserem bericht haben wir aber auch
klar aufgezeigt dass das bundesheer
schon heute nicht mehr in der lage ist
die österreicherinnen und österreicher
entsprechend zu schützen und welche
risiken damit verbunden sind
meine damen und herren das hört sich
alles dramatisch an ist aber leider
realität
wenn jetzt nicht in das bundesheer
investiert wird werden wir den hybriden
bedrohungen cyber angriffen und dem
systemischen terrorismus künftig hilflos
ausgeliefert seien
unsere bisher erbrachten leistungen in
der katastrophenhilfe und beim
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz werden erheblich
eingeschränkt sein
wir werden die sicherungen des
österreichischen luftraums und die damit
verbundene souveränität und neutralität
nicht mehr wahrnehmen können und unsere
teilnahme an internationalen friedens
und stabilisierung seien setzen werden
wir signifikant zurück nehmen müssen was
ich fordere ist keine luxus armee was
ich fordere ist die mindestausstattung
eines funktionierenden bundesheeres zum
schutz der österreichischen bevölkerung
und der infrastruktur notwendig ist eine
schrittweise anhebung des
verteidigungsbudgets bis zum jahr 2030
auf ein prozent des
bruttoinlandsproduktes
das ist eine jährliche steigerung von
nur 0 0 38 prozent der gesamten
wirtschaftsleistung in österreich und
ohnehin weit weniger als der
internationale standard von diesem
sicherheitskonzept profitiert die
österreichische wirtschaft die forschung
klein und mittelbetriebe und es werden
auch arbeitsplätze damit gesichert
sicherheit und neutralität muss uns
etwas wert sein
das bundesheer schützt die
österreicherinnen und österreicher
55.000 soldaten davon überwiegend
soldatinnen und soldaten aus der miliz
stehen dafür bereit
junge polizistinnen und polizisten
dürfen frühestens nach zwölf monaten
ausbildungszeit das erste mal bei einer
streife mitgehen und amtshandlungen
quasi über die schulter schauen
unsere kunden sowie die über 1000
töchter und söhne die jetzt hier am
heldenplatz angetreten sind werden
derzeit in nur sechs monaten für den
einsatz in komplexen szenarien wie ich
es zuvor geschildert habe ausgebildet
das ist ein aus militärischer sicht
gerade noch vertretbarer zeitraum
soldaten und soldatinnen mit weniger
ausbildungszeit in einsätze senden zu
wollen ist daher unmoralisch und
verantwortungslos zugleich am tag ihrer
ersten einsatzbereitschaft schicken wir
aber diese soldaten nach hause
das führt dazu dass auch in personeller
hinsicht weder unsere präsidentin
verbände noch die miliz einsatzbereit
sind ja zu mir gesagt sagt auch ja zu
einer wehrpflicht von acht monaten an zu
geloben soldatinnen soldaten
sie werden in kürze geloben die
österreichische bevölkerung zu schützen
und mit der waffe zu verteidigen
eine angelobung ist ein sehr bewegender
moment und wieder bürgermeister stand
ich auch vor knapp 40 jahren an ihrer
stelle mit ihrem ich gelobe übernehmen
sie verantwortung verantwortung für sich
selbst für ihre kameraden und
verantwortung für die sicherheit unserer
blick österreich mit bewusst
dass dies für sie eine neue
lebenssituation ist
sie haben ihre gewohnte umgebung ihre
familie und freunde und arbeitsstätte
verlassen um für ein halbes jahr den
dienst mit der waffe zu verwenden
dafür gebührt ihnen mein respekt meine
anerkennung und meinen dank
gewährleisten wir ihnen dafür die
erforderliche ausbildungszeit und geben
wir ihnen die notwendige ausstattung
dafür das sind wir ihnen schuldig
soldaten und soldatinnen beschützen die
gesellschaft und tun das unter einsatz
ihres lebens
das sollten wir uns immer vor augen
führen
soldatinnen und soldaten
ich wünsche ihnen alles gute für die
zukunft und eine interessante dienstzeit
beim österreichischen bundesheer ihren
angehörigen und freunden kann ich
versichern dass die
ausbildungsverantwortlichen
unteroffiziere und offiziere alles daran
setzen dass wir ihre söhne und töchter
nach ihrem dienst wieder wohlbehalten
nach hause entlassen können
es lebe das österreichische bundesheer
es lebe die republik österreich
[Applaus]
etwas umgang und aber mit einer sehr
großen freude darf ich ihnen eine
sportlerin und einem sportler vorstellen
es ist dies hehre sportlerin frau
korporal verena peiner die bei der
letzten leichtathletik-weltmeisterschaft
in der kategorie siebenkampf mit 6.560
punkten
das richtig große gewonnen hat uns ist
natürlich damit auch die österreichische
rekord aber in im siebenkampf und
natürlich auch sehr gerne seine sportler
zugführer lukas weißhaidinger der
innviertler hat bei der leichtathletik
weltmeisterschaften in der kategorie
diskuswurf mit einer weite von 66 82
meter große gewonnen und besonders
erwähnenswert das war die erste meile
hat eine männer bewerb seit austragung
bedienender leichtathletik
weltmeisterschaften was mich noch
besonders freut so wie ich sind beide
aus oberösterreich
[Applaus]
sehr verehrter herr bundespräsident hohe
festversammlung liebe rekrutinnen und
rekruten die wir mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger natürlich eine erfreuliche
szene die wir eben erleben durften
der nationalfeiertag bietet gelegenheit
uns darauf zu besinnen was uns als
österreicherinnen und österreichern aus
mach was wir für unser land tun wollen
was jede und jeder von uns dazu
beitragen kann das
bundesverfassungsgesetz über die
neutralität österreichs markiert einen
wendepunkt in der geschichte unseres
landes
er setzte einen schlusspunkt unter eine
schreckliche woche von grieg vernichtung
und besatzung gleichzeitig wurde damit
auch der beginn einer neuen ära
eingeläutet
in der österreich als souveräner und
neutraler staat wiederaufnahme in die
völkergemeinschaft gefunden hat heute
steht er unser land für freiheit frieden
und wohlstand und gilt international als
ort der diplomatischen drücken und des
ausgleichs
wir leben in einer unruhigen welt auch
in unserer nachbarschaft ein blick in
den osten europas genügt unser
bundesheer kommt in seinen vielfältigen
und wichtigen aufgaben seit jahrzehnten
diesen aufgaben nach wir haben daher all
unseren soldatinnen und soldaten sehr zu
danken für ihren täglichen einsatz nicht
nur in der landesverteidigung sondern
auch wenn sie an entlegenen orten der
welt den frieden sichern
oder wenn sie
bei humanitären einsätzen im inland
menschenleben schützen und retten
das motto helfen wo es andere nicht mehr
können steht für dieses
selbstverständnis unseres bundesheeres
und spiegelt auch grundlegende
überzeugungen unseres landes wieder
engagement hilfsbereitschaft und
stabilität
wir müssen unserem bundesheer daher auch
in zukunft jenes augenmerk schenken das
es verdient
der verteidigungsminister hat es ja
ebenso wie der herr bürgermeister zuvor
sehr hervorgegangen liebe gute wirkung
unsere guten sie stehen stellvertretend
für alle jungen menschen in unserem land
ich bitte sie eindringlich sich nicht
nur für die sicherheit unseres landes
einzusetzen sondern auch für die
vitalität unserer demokratie
es ist unsere und auch ihre
verpflichtung unsere demokratischen
errungenschaften zu hüten das mittel
wird zu suchen den dialog in den
mittelpunkt unseres handelns zu stellen
und die zusammengehörigkeit in einem
geeinten europa zu stärken
mein appell an sie bringen sie sich ein
gestalten sie mit verteidigen sie die
werte unserer demokratie auch eine
gefestigte demokratie wie die unsere
bedarf ständiger achtsamkeit und
aufmerksamkeit und vor allem hören sie
einander zu gehen sie aufeinander zu und
aufeinander ein
hören sie nicht auf jene die das
trennende vor das gemeinsame stellen
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger vor
30 jahren fiel der eiserne vorhang der
kein vorhang war
sondern ein todesstreifen er zog sich
wie der bürgermeister schon
hervorgehoben hat mehr als 40 jahre lang
vom norden bis in den süden durch ganz
europa teilte den kontinent in zwei
welten trennte familien freunde und
nachbarn und bestimmte auch das
schicksal österreichs
seither hat unser land enorme
fortschritte gemacht
und das liegt insbesondere an beitritt
zur europäischen union vor bald 25
jahren
österreich hat von der eu mitgliedschaft
in vieler hinsicht nachhaltig profitiert
der europäische union ist das
erfolgreichste friedensprojekt der
geschichte ihr erfolg beruht nicht nur
auf wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
errungenschaften sondern auch in der
überwindung von krieg und gewaltsamen
konflikten auf der grundlage gemeinsamer
werte genau auf jene gemeinsam an und
verbinden werte besinnen wir uns am
heutigen tag demokratie
rechtsstaatlichkeit menschenrechte
wir bauen gemeinsam an der wir noch
nicht die einfachen zukunft unseres
europäischen hauses nur ein starkes
europa kann auch weiterhin garant für
die sicherung des friedens und des
wohlstands seiner bürgerinnen und bürger
seien sie unsere rekrutinnen und
rekruten gehören zum besten was unser
land zu bieten hat der republik in
dieser art zu kindern verlangt mir und
uns allen größten respekt ab ich möchte
ihnen heute im namen der gesamten
österreichischen bundesregierung für den
einsatz sehr herzlich danken
ich wünsche ihnen viel glück und alles
erdenklich gute
wir sind stolz auf sie hoch lebe unsere
republik österreich
hoch lebe unser gemeinsames europa
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie hören nun die festansprache des
herrn bundespräsidenten professor doktor
alexander van der bellen
es folgt eine festmusik und ein gebet
gesprochen von der militär geistlichkeit
sehr geehrte ehrengäste und festgäste
liebe mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger ganz
besonders begrüße ich die allerjüngsten
unter uns die noch lange nicht zum
wehrdienst eingezogen werden
aber ganz mein ganz besonderer gruß gilt
natürlich heute am nationalfeiertag
unseren rekrutinnen und rekruten sie
werden in kürze ihr gelöbnis als
soldaten und soldatinnen des
österreichischen bundesheers leisten
meine damen und herren am
nationalfeiertag lohnt es sich
vielleicht die letzten monate das letzte
jahr zurück zu schauen wir hatten ein
ereignisreiches politisches jahr
politische monate hinter uns in den
nachwehen des verstörenden ebit skandals
wurde erstmals in der zweiten republik
ein minister zur entlastung
vorgeschlagen
erstmals in der zweiten republik wurde
einer bundesregierung das misstrauen der
mehrheit des nationalrats ausgesprochen
und erstmals wurde eine bundesregierung
angelobt die nicht aus einer mehrheit
des nationalrats hervorgehen
diese zeit war eine prüfung unserer
bundesverfassung und unsere staatlichen
institutionen
beide haben diese prüfung bestanden
die regeln der bundesverfassung haben
uns den weg aus der krise gewesen
sie waren wie ich schon einmal erwähnt
habe eine wie eine landkarte die den
pfad gewiesen hat und auch unsere
institutionen haben sich als krisenfest
erwiesen
und ich denke heute am nationalfeiertag
können wir ein wenig stolz darauf sein
meine damen und herren österreich hat
vor kurzem einen neuen nationalrat
gewählt der diese woche erstmals
zusammengetreten ist
einige herausforderungen sind von der
zukünftigen bundesregierung jedenfalls
zu bewältigen
einige davon sind wir müssen alles tun
um die klimakrise nicht ausufern zu
lassen
wir brauchen einen sorgfältigen umgang
mit fragen der sicherheit und der justiz
wir müssen durch innovationsförderndes
maßnahmen die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung österreichs verstärken
wir müssen an der weltpolitik fähigkeit
des gemeinsamen unseres vereinten
europas arbeiten und lastet natürlich
wir sollten alles tun damit die
gesetzlich verbürgten gleichberechtigung
zwischen mann und frau auch gelebte
praxis wird derzeit finden wie sie
wissen gespräche zur bildung einer neuen
bundesregierung statt die gute
österreichische lösung entsteht wenn man
erkennt dass es neben der eigenen
position und der des
verhandlungspartners noch eine dritte
gibt die womöglich noch besser ist als
die beiden anderen weil es eine
gemeinsame lösung ist eine im besten
sinne des wortes österreichische lösung
daher meine bitte an alle verhandelten
parteien finden sie gemeinsam die beste
lösung für österreich
meine damen und herren das bundesheer
trägt wesentlich bei zur gewährleistung
unserer staatlichen souveränität zum
schutz der verfassungsmäßigen
einrichtungen und der kritischen
infrastruktur zum schutz der bevölkerung
auch im katastrophenfall und zur
gesamtstaatlichen handlungsfähigkeit in
krisensituationen und ich habe bereits
mehrfach darauf hingewiesen und die
studie ist noch einmal dass diese
fähigkeiten durch ausreichende
ressourcen zuweisung gewährleistet
werden müssen
denn unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
verdienen die bestmögliche ausrüstung
für ihre einsätze
sehr geehrte rekrutinnen und rekruten
sie werden heute am nationalfeiertag ihr
gelöbnis als soldatinnen und soldaten in
aller öffentlichkeit ablegen
sie werden in einem herd ihnen dass ich
den zielen freiheit schutz der
demokratie eintreten für die achtung der
menschenrechte hilfe für
katastrophenopfer und engagement bei
internationalen friedens aufgaben
verschrieben hat mit ihren dienst
leisten sie einen wertvollen beitrag zum
schutz
und zur sicherheit unserer
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger ich wünsche
ihnen ein für die zeit ihres
wehrdienstes alles gute und nicht nur
für diese zeit sondern auch für die zeit
danach wie kommt mit sich es lebe das
österreichische bundesheer es lebe die
republik österreich und es lebe unser
gemeinsames friedliches europa
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die festversammlung liebe an zu geloben
rekrutinnen und rekruten im jahre 1955
hat sich österreich für die
immerwährende neutralität entschieden
das gelöbnis unserer väter nie wieder
krieg soll unter uns nicht in
vergessenheit geraten
unser christlicher glaube und der glaube
der völker jede religion muss sich in
den dienst des guten stellen heilig ist
allein was dem frieden dient was eint
und nicht trennt was aufbaut und nicht
vernichtet
liebe soldatinnen und soldaten
sie geloben heute in dieser stunde
feierlich mit allen ihren kräften der
republik österreich und unserem
österreichischen volk zu dienen
der dienst von soldatinnen und soldaten
in einem demokratischen rechtsstaat ist
immer friedensdienst ich wünsche euch
und ihnen für die kommenden monate ihrer
zeit beim österreichischen bundesheer
viel soldatenglück mut und kraft sowie
eine gesinnung der solidarität wie sie
unserem christsein in jesus entspricht
denn christus ist unser friede der segen
gottes sei mit ihnen
gnade sie mit euch um friede von gott
unserem vater und unserem herrn und
heiland jesus christus
ich möchte ihnen alles gute wünschen
sie grüßen mit der heutigen herrnhuter
losungen und sie segnen mit dem
segenswort de maronitischen segen aus
dem fünften buch mose 14 vers 2 du bist
ein heiliges folgt dem herrn deinem gott
uns der herr hat dich erwählt dass du
sein eigentum sei es aus allen völkern
die auf erden sind wir haben heute schon
darüber gesprochen in der
michaelerkirche wir können das er wählt
sein des volkes israel im sinne des
apostels paulus auf die menschheit
übertragen und die gnade die uns von
gott wer zukommt das möchte ich ihnen
heute auch zu sprechen
auch im sinne des milchmanns tevje in
anatevka der da sagt und bedauert
eigentlich gott macht keine ferien
daher segne dich und behüte dich der
herr lasse leuchten sein angesicht über
dir um 2 diabetiker der herr erhebe sein
angesicht auf dich und gebe dir frieden
[Musik]
lieber an zu gehobene rekruten und
rekrutinnen liebe kameraden möge gott
der herr euren frieden schüttelt den
dienst in unserem österreichischen
bundesheer segen in im namen des vaters
und des sohnes und des heiligen geistes
im namen allahs des gnädigen des
barmherzigen liebe rekrutinnen und
rekruten
ich bitte den allmächtigen gott möge er
euren einsatz für den frieden für unsere
heimat unsere republik österreich und
für das miteinander segnen armin
liebe soldatinnen und soldaten möge der
segen der propheten adam moses jesus und
mohammed unsere heilige alle der zwölf
imame und erläuterten die über jedem
volk sein der schöpfung beginnen kraft
und freizeit geben bei der noch aufgaben
die sie zu bewältigen haben mögen ihre
eingesetzten mittel effektiv sein und
sie zum ziel führen
seit stets mit friedlichen dasein mit
ihrem glaubensweg so mit ihnen frieden
mit gott in frieden mit menschen
unabhängig von rasse glaube und herkunft
und nicht zuletzt auch in frieden mit
euch selbst die sprechende zunge von
us-daten vom heiligen allee möglich zu
sein stets unseren wegbegleiter sein
die göttliche wahrheit segne uns allen
die ewigen wahrheit
wir kommen nun zum höhepunkt der
angelobung das tri gelöbnis wird heuer
erstmals von zwei rekruten nämlich
hiltrud nina reese und rekrut david
montanes schnickmann gesprochen nachdem
die eingetretene rekruten wieder
eingetreten sind hören sie die
bundeshymne danach ertönt die
europahymne
[Musik]
das ganze halt dinge truppe gar
vertreten
angesagte rekrut ein vertreter
tom sich gut dann sprecht uns nach ich
glaube mein vaterland die republik
österreich und sein volk zu schützen und
mit der waffe zu verteidigen
ich gelobe den gesetzen und den
gesetzmäßigen behörden treue und
gehorsam zu leisten
alle befehle meiner vorgesetzten
[Applaus]
pünktlich und genau zu befolgen
mit allen manager ashton
der republik österreich und den eltern
endlich in folge
lima
[Applaus]
gut eingestellte rekruten ein drittel
der gare eintritte
ihren formationen ihre informationen
presse typ das ganze rechtsschutz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ganze habe ihre information
oberst stefan kirschner meldet nun die
beendigung der militärischen feier und
bittet um weitere befehle mit dem ausmaß
der militärmusik der ehrenformation
endet dieser festakt dazu nochmals der
hinweis direkt im anschluss im inneren
burghof zur abgabe der waffen ab kann
dort aber nicht besucht werden sondern
erst im bereich des bahnhofsplatzes
ehrenformation pressemeldungen und herrn
bundespräsidenten das ganze recht herr
bundespräsident oberst kirchner meldet
die beendigung der feierlichen
angelobung und bittet um weitere befehle
das ganze hat ihre information schuld
und der information kommando übernehmen
aus marschieren
[Musik]
meine damen und herren noch ein hinweis
um 12 uhr geht es hier am wieder hinten
platz mit dem programm weiter und das
wird sie das moderatoren-team peter pohl
fw koalition radio wien und peter fähig
übernehmen und sie durch den heutigen
tag führen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ich darf mich an dieser stelle für ihre
teilnahme am festakt bedanken mich
namens des österreichischen bundesheeres
von ihnen verabschieden und noch einen
schönen